welcome to a fresh take on the news
putting you at the center of the
national conversation about the issues
that matter to you most
tonight our prime minister is under
investigation the commissioner of the
country's biggest police force has
resigned
and positive role models are seemingly
in short supply
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
tonight as a crisis of leadership grips
public life our viewers panel from
across the country
will share their stories they'll have
their say
and they'll hold our studio guest to
account
in the studio tonight former speaker of
the house of commons john burko
palm sandu former chief superintendent
in the metropolitan police
greg dyke who's led organizations
ranging from the bbc to the football
association
and founder and ceo byp network [ __ ]
oniwinde
the big question tonight
do we have the leaders we deserve
let's start as we always do with our
viewers panel
and talk to louise brown louise you're
in sunderland
hi
um i just want to say i think our prime
minister has let us down as leader of
this country
um my sister actually passed away during
the lockdown restrictions
of christmas 2020
and when i heard about the partygate
scandal
my first thought was that i feel
absolutely immense guilt because i last
i missed her last
christmas
and it's something that i thought really
long and hard about before christmas
because she had been seriously ill and
intensive care
before this and i thought you know
should i just go and see her at
christmas who would know but
who would know about that but i decided
not the right thing it was to follow the
lockdown restrictions
so now every time i hear about a new
revelation about party gay i feel sick
to my stomach and like i say
extremely guilty that i didn't see her
last christmas
and in fact i never saw her again
um
and when he's asked to resign boris
johnson apparently just sings about i
will survive so
it's a real slap in the face to british
people
luis do you
specifically
hold the prime minister responsible for
your feeling of disgust
yes i do because he's the one that was
announcing the rules and
to then pretend that he didn't know the
rules at one point
he's the one who told the nation the
rule so i do hold him responsible yeah
okay stay there for a moment uh let's go
to steve diasha
steve what's your view about this issue
of
leadership
i even saw on this panel uh yeah so my
view and style of this leadership
is quite frankly and easily
um what dan was hard for us
somebody we all know has broken the
rules
nobody you know we all followed the
rules
boris didn't involve the rules as as
other people but then again
he's admitted to it he's apologized to
it and now we've got to move on from
partygate let the police do what they
need to do we've got bigger things to
worry about at the moment we are a
laughingstock on the world stage because
of this
when we need to stop boris and kiss the
army
locking homes having a jiving each other
when in theory in reality we need to be
thinking and concentrating more about
russia
and what they're going to do and come
together with nato and put a show of
unity together and get behind the prime
minister and unite the country
and let's get things back on track
all right thank you steve let's go to
derrick watson derek
i think you've got a question for our
studio
yes trevor my question this evening is
this valentine's day would you send
boris johnson a letter of love or a
letter of dismissal
thank you very much derek
so panel um
derek's question
this valentine's day
would you send boris johnson a love
letter
or a letter of dismissal pretty
uh
on the money there john burko oh without
hesitation i would send him a letter of
dismissal never has a prime minister
wielded so much power made so little
effective use of it and been and been
seen to be in quite such an indecent
haste to blow his own trumpet i've been
aware of 12 prime ministers in my
lifetime by a country mile boris johnson
is the worst he's a narcissist he
doesn't do the detail he's ritually
dishonest having a nodding acquaintance
with the truth at best only in elite
year he is responsible for a catalogue
of failures he is the most inarticulate
public speaker and prime minister i've
ever known he has no redeeming virtues
he stayed there far too long it is time
that he gave up office and beetled off
into the distance which would be an
enormous relief not just to this country
and to the european continent but to the
world and one of these days trevor i'll
try to tell you what i really think
well i i was going to say john that
there's it would be helpful if you got
off the fence on this question but do
you genuinely mean that he has no
rederming the redeeming virtues you
heard from steve dasher there we're
facing putin
we're facing
the aftermath of covid we're facing all
kinds of things and
he would say that of course boris
johnson has seen us through some of the
worst days
yes i don't buy that argument i respect
steve's sincerity and i know his loyalty
but i don't buy that argument and i'll
tell you why if you look at historical
examples there are many in which a
sitting prime minister has been turfed
out and easily and very capably replaced
by someone else similar arguments were
made about margaret thatcher who was
certainly a very dynamic and forthright
leader in international affairs of
vastly greater competence and judgment
than boris johnson but she was replaced
by john major when there was talk of
further wars there had been conflict in
the gulf and so on so the idea that you
can't change the incumbent because of
the present situation at pertaining to
the ukraine is wrong and with all due
respect the idea that president putin is
tweaking at his boots at the thought of
an inaudible lecture from boris johnson
is laughable greg dyke um
you've got a lot of experience as a
leader and of leadership um is there
anything positive to be said about the
prime minister
well he's got charisma he's known
you know he's probably the one of the
best known prime ministers we've ever
had
but i don't think there's much else
that's to be said in favor
i think
i i you really got to go back to the
conservative party and say they had no
right to put this bloke as their leader
in the first place and most of them most
of the mps you ever talked to the
conservative mps wouldn't have made him
leader he became leader because of
brexit and what happened to that
particular time
and i think the disaster was always
going to happen it was waiting to happen
and now it's it's happened now i also
believe he will hang on
but i would think the conservative idea
at some stage
that he's not going to win again
paul where do you stand on this
i think it's very difficult to be in
those positions of leadership but i
think that if you lose the trust and
confidence of your either your party or
the people who are supposed to support
you then you do need to look again at
your style of leadership and whether or
not you should be there and it is about
for me it's about accountability and if
there is no accountability if you're
setting the rules and then you're
breaking them then where does that
accountability start and finish
okay i'd give boris a letter of
dismissal and my only
upset or frustration is i don't know who
i would give a letter of love to um to
replace him and i think that's how many
people feel and the tory government in
general has been so corrupt i mean we've
seen one rule for them one wall for
everybody else if it's not party gay
it's giving contracts to their friends
it's you know not giving nhs workers a
pay rise it's giving themselves more
expenses or pay rises and it's just been
frustrating to see um so many of us have
really suffered during um this pandemic
period and to see you know basically two
halves you know rich getting richer poor
getting poorer and a government that
just doesn't seem to care for the people
and that's why it's hard you know you
dismiss boris johnson but who who would
replace him and i think that's what a
lot of us feel well of course the
question is do we get the leaders we
deserve and in a sense actually what
you're saying what you're saying is
we haven't got
a much choice right now yeah exactly we
don't have much choice um which is
really really frustrating when i look at
the tory party i i generally don't know
who would replace him and when i look at
labour like kia starmar and sadly he
just doesn't come across well to many
people he doesn't have much charisma we
don't know what he's saying he doesn't
appeal to the young people or really
anyone in general and so i think the
country is just you know confused at
what to do
all right let's go back to our viewers
panel and i i want to talk to jen swaby
who i think
has a
view about this prime minister jan
yeah i think
we want too much from our political
leaders expecting their moral choices to
be beyond reproach um it means that
politicians are actually too busy trying
to be liked rather than focusing on
their job and personally i don't care if
the politician has an affair or in this
case a
um party during lockdown
um i personally bent the rules a little
and i'm sure that a lot of other people
did too
whether boris is morally questionable or
not doesn't prevent him from making good
political decisions that he believes are
right for the country if he's going to
be given a vote of no confidence then i
think it should be because of because of
bad political decisions and not his
social life
that's interesting because i i can see
there's quite a lot of support from
panel from this point of view do you do
you think that you know when we discuss
this question of boris johnson's
capabilities his leadership and so on
that we're focusing on the wrong
aspects of his leadership to judge him
yes
yes i think we are i think we should be
looking at um how he's handled the
pandemic how he's handling his political
decisions not what he's doing in his
social life if he's having a birthday
party or not
all right well let's uh stay stay there
because that's a very interesting point
let's talk to peter jensko who i think
has a
slightly different view on this issue of
the importance of character peter yeah
um i absolutely believe that a
politician's moral conscious actually
does affect their ability to be a good
leader
if you can't tell the truth if you
if you
cannot act with dignity to the art to
the office that you're in
then you're no good okay
all these people say oh you know he's
done this he's done that what he hasn't
done what he hasn't done
you show respect for the british people
respect from the people that died
respect for the rules that he set what
makes me sick
is the the the train of people that are
sent out onto skype everywhere day after
day to defend absolutely indefensible
and to say oh you know and we're being
ghastly all the time
and his his moral confidence is
absolutely fundamentally directly
in in proportion to what a leader needs
if he's wishy-washy if he lies which he
does and which he is how how can you
take him seriously how can you how can
you trust this man to make a political
decision when he can't even tell the
truth
okay prime minister's questions
hold it there for a second peter let me
come back to uh jan make the case to him
that
there's a better another way to look at
this
i just don't think politics should be
based on personality i think um a
political party is what we vote in not
um the prime minister it shouldn't be
um politics based on personality it
should be politics based on what the
party stands for
and we spend too much time
holding people to account and to
standards that it's impossible for them
to keep while they're in the public eye
and under public scrutiny
greg nike um
our audience is pretty well divided
divided here actually
uh
should we be judging prime minister on
the basis of what he does or doesn't do
with a cake
well that's not the that's not the
question the question here is were there
a set of rules that the rest of us were
following that they weren't it's as
simple as that and if it's if it's in
the end demonstrated
and shown that they were breaking the
rules then they can't stay
it's as simple as that's not difficult i
mean a lot of people had very difficult
we all went to old funerals other things
of people and it was incredibly
difficult period
and to find out that actually there was
something different happening inside
downing street there were parties after
party there was fun after fun and they
were joking about it as you saw
uh that was the worst and they were
joking about it now that's
there is an investigation going on with
on that greg so let you be a little bit
careful what we say about it but the
basic point is did that make him a less
good prime minister yeah well i don't
think he was a particularly good prime
minister no but it did make him a less
good prime minister because you couldn't
believe him
and once you can't believe the prime
minister you can't stay in the job and
and i think i mean i haven't yet to meet
anyone who voted
for johnson last time uh who's who
anyone who voted against him who's
changed their mind and i think what has
happened is there will be enough people
who have changed their mind because of
what he's done they'll lose the next
election with him all right
coming up as the prime minister travels
to scotland
do our leaders need to be one of us
[Music]
welcome back to the great debate where
this week we're asking
do we have the leaders we deserve
prime minister spending the start of his
half-term break visiting scotland as
part of a leveling up tour of the uk
but of course boris johnson isn't the
only leader who matters in british
politics
let's go straight to our viewers panel
and john soderbergh in lancaster
john you think that there are better
leaders elsewhere possibly
yeah it could be it's a relative term
um
i think the question i would like to ask
is do our leaders need to be like us it
sounds a very simple question but it
covers a lot of complexities
okay thank you
john's question for you our panel is do
our leaders need to be like us
greg
if someone had told me when i was 20
that
50 years later
um the itonians would still dominate
british politics i wouldn't have
believed it i'd have thought this is not
possible so do they if it depends what
you want if you want them to win
elections clearly they can win an
election you don't have to be to win
elections do they have to have come from
a background
where they understand some of the big
issues
of of existence in this country yeah i
think it would be far better if they did
john berko i don't think it's essential
that they're like us i think that the
empirical evidence of who's led a party
to election victory rather proves the
point
sometimes a leader can
win support from the public precisely
because of his
peccadillos and for quite a long time
that was true of boris johnson i think
people identified with the fact that he
was a bit disorganized a bit disheveled
a bit discombobulated
much of the time from one day to the
next not quite knowing what was next and
there was a sense in which i think
people thought well i'm a bit like that
and therefore i don't hold it against
him but he did have a certain charm i
think that's now wearing thin i think
one respect however in which a leader
does have to be like the public is
having some basic sense of right and
wrong
a responsibility to people
a real demonstration of the conviction
that there's a we as well as a me and
that's where i think boris johnson falls
down he's completely about himself palm
i was just going to say that the leaders
should be representative of our
communities and changing britain because
when you talk about cost of living and
you're talking about price rises and
energy crisis if you don't know how much
your bill is you don't know how much a
loaf of bread is how can you possibly
represent our communities and the rest
of britain and i think it's important
that people do know and they don't have
to you know they have to worry about
their bank accounts just like normal
people do i'm going to come to you the
second kick but let me first
bring in stephen fairly
um in scotland stephen
i mean the question is do we have the
leaders we deserve um
and scotland we don't even have the
leaders that we vote for to be honest
with you we haven't had the tories and
power in scotland in nearly 60 years
which is a long time um
so that is
one major issue i mean boris
was up in scotland today
um ticking the tick in the box as they
say you know visit visiting scotland and
ticking the box
and he's the best advert for
independence when it comes to scotland
he's the best advert for it because it
doesn't have any moral compass
uh to be the leader of the uk
you know you know
the uk is made up of four nations he has
to be in touch
with the four nations and his people and
he's not he's not in touch with any of
the nations
except um
maybe eating a lot of us so no he's not
he's not the leader we want we voted for
in scotland
okay thank you thank you very much
indeed okay
here's an example it's a general
principle to what extent does a leader
really have to
feel like he or she is part of the tribe
i think the question is what is the
tribe i think one thing i've noticed
with the uk is that it's so divided you
know each one of us here are different
for example we have different
backgrounds privileges etc so i would
say okay you know i'd love a leader
that's more like the working class that
came from nothing to something or that
understands what's going on on the
ground so that understands heat or eat
is a real thing and it isn't just um
pull yourself by your bootstrap and you
know go have that little sandwich and
have less showers i just you know when
you hear some of the things that are
being said to the general public in
order to deal with the current crisis
it's just like you're so out of touch
what is going on yeah i get that but let
me give you an example i mean it's it's
the examples of all examples people will
say who is britain's greatest leader
ever
always churchill
war leader
well people most people would say
greatest leader and he was the
descendant of dukes he was born in a
palace he was always rich
he led in war with many privations and
so on but people would still say
this is the person we identified with
yes because there was an overriding goal
in a situation without precedent and he
was almost universally judged to be the
best person for the job that he's
completely different trevor from the
situation we find today and i suppose
okay i'd like to lob into the bar well
it's very simply this does that leader
get up in the morning
and strain every muscle and sinew to
better the lot of people less fortunate
than him or her nobody okay in all
conscience can say boris johnson does
that
let me go back let me let me stick with
kk for the moment it's it's a lack of
empathy it's a lack of understanding
that there are people that are truly
suffering i think if boris and a lot
more people notorious maybe more than
moderators can actually understand that
people just need better you know better
healthcare better jobs nhs need better
pay you know give us that energy cap
that didn't have to have to happen and
but instead it's all about profits for
the biggest businesses and
during again during um kovid there's
been this case-shaped recovery i've seen
it i'm on the line of like both sides
and the rich are getting rich in ways
that i've never it's incredible to see
where the poor people are truly
suffering so if we just had a leader who
understands that and cares about the
actual citizens um you know being the
best that they can representing the
global economy then we'll do better as a
country so we need leaders let's go to
kathleen morris um kathleen morris uh
there are other ways in which people can
identify with their leaders not
necessarily geographically
i think you've got a view about um
men male and female leaders i certainly
have
you know female leaders they tend to
look at things differently
we're more creative with their ideas and
how to solve problems we aren't afraid
to take tough decisions but we do it
compassionately a female leader would
most definitely would not have long 200
pounds to the utility companies and ask
does geopublic to pay it back
a female leader
is
if you're looking into your history
we've got angela merkel golda meir
indira gandhi and yeah margaret patra
why is it so difficult for the men to
take direction from female leaders or
bosses
the percentage of male and females in
the world is 50.4 percent men and 49.6
percent female oh yeah
go on now just quickly cathy just just
checking i noticed that theresa may
wasn't in that list
she hadn't timed it well but yeah all
right we'll put teresa in because she
was a good leader if she'd have been
allowed to stay in a job
okay thank you stay there
palm sandu
you were well you are a female and a
female leader do you do you think
kathleen's right
i think that there are some people
within our society who do find it very
difficult to take
instructions orders you know for us it
was orders instructions or to actually
work for female bosses and it anyway
you're in a pretty all pretty male
environment yeah and i have actually had
people in my office who have said well
you can't say that to me where i've
ended up throwing them out of the office
type thing because some
men especially
let's not beat around the bush it's men
don't like taking instructions from
women and there is that that little
to and fro before you have to prove
yourself to be as good as if not twice
as good as your colleagues just to get
your point across and even like if i
could just add one more thing because
there's myself and there were a couple
of other female leaders in different
industries and we actually um put
together this group called the he
peeting group and that's because
male colleagues would repeat what we'd
said and it would be heard whereas when
we said it it just wasn't heard
okay thank you we're going to talk about
a woman leader now you're watching the
great debate up next pretty patel starts
looking for a new met police
commissioner but does it matter who
chooses our leaders
[Music]
you're watching the great debate
do we have the leaders we deserve
the person in charge of the country's
biggest police force resigned a few days
ago dame cressida dick said she was left
with no choice after the mayor of london
made it clear he didn't have confidence
in her leadership
today the federation representing rank
and file officers has said it has no
confidence in sadiq khan
now it's up to the home secretary priddy
patel to find the right leader to
replace dame cressida
let's kick things off with a question
from simon white on our viewers panel
simon what's your view about this
um well who should choose our leaders um
obviously uh pretty patel uh the home
secretary is about to appoint
the new commissioner of the met police
and yet i for one am uncomfortable with
this link between police and the ruling
party in parliament um
to to govern us properly we have to have
parliament that sets the rules but a
police force that then applies them
fairly without favor
and things happening at the moment worry
me for instance the um the downing
street inquiry into partygate
there's no doubt that boris johnson
was
definitely helped by the fact that the
met police inquiry has held up the full
report
now i'm not saying there's collusion
but the fact that there is scope for
people to suspect collusion is just not
good for anybody
we need to be confident that police are
acting fairly uh in all our interests
and it worries me when we see things
like this happen and you've got a
question for our panel then
well who should choose our leaders uh is
basically the question for the panel um
should it be down to the home secretary
to choose the new commissioner of the
met police thank you simon so there's
simon's question for you
who should choose our leaders pom sandu
it's it's really a sharp question for
this choice of the nation's top cop
isn't it i think we we've ended up in a
very difficult situation because
politics and policing should never have
been mixed and they should always have
been kept separate but we've got
ourselves into a legislative mess where
it can only be the home secretary in
conjunction with the mayor of london but
it doesn't matter whether they're
conservatives labor or any other
political party that's what the
legislation says but i do agree that
politics and policing should never ever
have been allowed to mix in this way
because there is that there is that
perception now where the public are
thinking
they're investigating the government are
there favors being done as your guests
just said
all right we're going to come i'm going
to come back to you on that but let me
ask another
uh person who has worn the uniform james
james what is your view about this
i have to agree totally travel with the
superintendent basically that politics
and police should never mix never in a
million years should be mixing these two
of them together
um
i was a rural cop for best part of 20
years so i can't even imagine what it's
like placing a big city
from that point of view um
however from the mets point of view
the prison
performance in recent times hasn't been
the best does it um from the whatsapp
groups
to the position of a vigil for female
murdered by an officer
right through now to the
downward street parties that they
weren't going to investigate and then
decided to investigate it's been a
complete and utter embarrassment if
truth be told
however my point would be if clarissa
dick is to resign because of her actions
of people in an organization that she's
the commander of
should the same rules not be applied to
our political elite let's come back in
to the studio
kk there there is an issue here isn't
there that
somebody may be really liked by the rank
and file and we gathered that was
probably true about crested dick but
actually the public pays for the police
and the public
on their representatives should maybe
have the upper hand
in deciding who gets to run that
organization where what do you think
yeah i believe that the public should
actually vote for who should be the new
commissioner and the thought of as they
do in america they vote for yeah this is
uh police we know this is controlled
yeah exactly we know that currently that
the public do not have much faith in the
police we feel like they belong to the
government and they don't care about us
the everyday people and and to have
preeti patel choose the new commissioner
is probably the worst thing that could
happen that that sets us back even
further you know and then chrissida the
crusader dick uh so i think that the
public should vote why not do something
different why not show us the top five
and then we choose we investigate who um
who who the potential new recruit is and
then we vote but i don't think peter
patel should have a hand in it because
we just we her policies are shocking um
nobody i think she's probably one of the
worst hated mps there is
so that's my own personal let's not go
down that road
quickly i was just going to add to okay
certain comments there it's really
important to have the trust and
confidence of our communities and if you
haven't got the trust and confidence of
our communities you cannot police by
consent yeah but just very quickly
if you put that job out to a vote isn't
that politics straight away why that's
the public voting that's not politicians
voting
i actually think that's a really good
idea
james what do you think
there's the idea of putting the job of
uh police commissioner or similar jobs
out to vote by the public
how would the public know how that
particular police officer out of five of
them perform it has to be a police
officer in charge of the force it cannot
go out to industry etc because then it
does become politicized
i understand the feelings but i do think
it has to be a police officer in charge
and how the public going to know
who to vote for
all right okay let's greg um
let's let's i don't want to go too far
into your extensive biography but of
course you were the boss of the bbc and
um famously very popular with the staff
not so popular with the government but
the governors more than the government
or the people who the government had
appointed and i upset the government of
the day but uh or or the bbc dude
um
i i think this is an incredibly tough
job
to run the met because
culturally the organization is in need
of significant change
and you have it's a big organization how
do you get in you've got to get in at
the bottom
to get that change you won't do it by
saying somebody's sitting in in the
headquarters and saying right now we're
going to be like this because it won't
happen you've got to persuade the people
who work for you to support what you are
doing and that makes it a very difficult
job but
it's probably doable if you get the
right person
uh i'm i'm not confident that the the
politicians will choose the right person
all right chris ilda basu
good evening chris ilda uh i think
you've been with us before what do you
what do you make of this debate about
who chooses the leader
one person cannot do
that job i think it needs more than one
person to do that job
oh that's interesting um
but what happens if they disagree i mean
somebody's got to make the decisions
don't they
yes but this you still need a team
with crested i didn't see a team behind
her at all if there was a crisis she was
there on her own stood on her own um
and making all the decisions where to me
there should be a team that makes that
decision if there's a crisis in another
country a devastating crisis that's that
happened you know to all women in in
this country um
there would be a team that would um
discuss or tell the public
what
exactly had happened and
what they're going to do okay thank you
chris ilda uh malcolm malcolm severum
what uh what's your view about
this issue
that's arisen in the last week
good evening well can i just say first
of all that um
leaders excellent leaders do lead by
example
and to be an excellent leader you are
held to a moral compass that is higher
than the people you're leading
so i think as palm said it's essential
the police maintain the trust
uh and the respect of the public they
are employed to serve
too many senior appointments nowadays
are dictated by wokeness
rather than the ability of the
individual to do the job okay kk
wokeness
problem
in leadership
so the question on wokeness i think um i
mean going back to boris that's a white
male who is not the greatest leader so i
think what we're looking for is someone
who's right for the job but we need to
look far and wide and find the right
people and like i said peter patel you
know she's an asian woman but so many
people don't identify when they look at
pretty patel her her views are very
different to so many other people so i
think it's about finding the right
leader who again is for the people
especially when it comes to you know the
met commissioner and i think at the
moment the community is just so divided
with the police i would love to see a
police force that is out on the street
smiling helping citizens helping people
and just you know letting us know that
they they've got our backs not making us
feel like oh my god there's police
behind me you let me sit up up tight and
i think that the right leader is someone
that will come forward and show that
they want to make a difference in the
police force there may be a different
pathway to that let's let's talk about
that
coming up on the great debates forget
about those in power what about the
everyday inspirational leaders who are
often the most important role models
[Music]
this is the great debate where our
guests and viewers panel are discussing
do we have the leaders we deserve
let's start with jordan sykes in our
viewers panel
uh jordan you're a primary school
teacher
who do you look to for leadership i
obviously myself tried to be a good role
model as much as possible and i think we
could always look to those are currently
in power but i think there's
i personally think there's obviously my
profession and lots of other professions
um who try to be good role models and we
probably feel like we're maybe not um
promoted or
supported in the
best way by those in power at the moment
so you are dealing with young people so
um
you've got a question about that for
our panel i think
yes sir sam do you think our government
should be doing more to give young
people good role models as well as
promoting those people who could be good
role models as well
thank you very much okay okay kk that
finger is pointing at you on this as uh
one authentically young person
what do you think absolutely i mean that
is the number one thing the government
should be doing i remember i tweeted
once at marcus radford uh rashford
should be prime minister that's how much
of a better job he was doing and i think
that but that's sad that you know we had
to get
don't say that to a manchester city fan
but
yeah there's so many people on the
ground doing incredible work every
single day and that care about people
generally and that don't get to be seen
they're not visible and so many people
feel despondent because they're not
seeing that role model visibility
everything we get on the news is
negative news every single day but we
just want to see people who have you
know done great work they've um you know
done well in their careers maybe they're
entrepreneurs they're social activists
people that just inspire other people to
to also do great work i think we've lost
that in the world we've lost the fact
that we're just here to yeah we have to
have shelter we have to have food but
we're ultimately here to serve other
people and help other people do better
and i think the government should be
promoting that showing people in their
neighborhoods that maybe grew up in i'm
from barking dagenham originally so
showing people in barking and dagnam
that are doing great work you know in
the uk and across the world and just
letting people know that they can aspire
to greatness but i think what we have is
a government that a privilege they grew
up you know in a world where they were
told from young they are going to be the
leaders this is what it is and they're
so disconnected from everyday people
that they don't see the need
to be fair i don't think that's true
about everybody who's in government but
i take the point john burko do you do
you think that
everyday leadership can do something to
counter
the kinds of
problem that we've been talking about so
far about national leadership
everyday leadership can do something to
counter the prevalent cynicism but it
has to be much better than it is now it
has to display empathy
and it has to demonstrate that words are
followed
by deeds the problem at the moment at
the heart of government is that
i don't see or hear many ministers who
demonstrate empathy with the people whom
they're intended and required to serve
and i constantly hear ministers mouthing
the mantra or the prime minister himself
doing so i take responsibility and i'm
left asking what do those words mean
when you want other people to lose their
jobs so you can keep yours if i can put
it in a sentence the one leader i found
more impressive in my time in office
than anyone else was the speaker's
chaplain who is now the bishop of dover
the right reverend rose hudson wilkin
every day she went about her work
thinking of others ministering to others
caring about others putting herself in
the position of others i don't see
anyone in this government who begins to
hold a candle all right to her
let's go back to our viewers panel and
talk to
nicholas stevenson you also come from
the education sector what's your view
about this everyday leadership point
i i wake up every morning privileged to
do my role i'm a ceo of a mullet academy
trust in newcastle
and i'm very much a public servant i am
there to serve the community i am there
to serve the children and i'm there to
be a role model
i'm there to be judged for parents i'm
there to be a social worker and nurse
i love my job
and there are so many great community
leaders out there who equally love their
job because the parents know that we
speak truth we have empathy with our
situation
i feel part of community i don't live in
it i'm certainly a key member of that
community
and i will ultimately take
responsibility properly for anything
that would go wrong in any of the
schools that i run i will hold my head
up and i speak the truth to people and i
think that's all this country wants is
somebody who's telling the truth who
understands where people are coming from
and
is doing the best job they can from the
moment they wake up palm
maybe we're looking in the wrong place
for the ideal of leadership and
the great leaders are perhaps the ones
whose names we don't often mention on tv
i think often you will find those great
leaders and they will be closer to home
because i think all of us would remember
that one teacher that motivated you that
made you do that a little bit more
studying and made you think that you
could achieve because my background
wasn't great
but i had somebody who believed in me
when i was very very young who pushed me
and you know when things get tough you
think about that person as a role model
who can actually make a difference and
influence and there are some sports
sports individuals who are those leaders
and those two teachers absolutely hat
off to them because they will make an
impact on a huge number of young people
as they're grown up and if you can make
that differentiation or make that
difference when they're young then of
course that will follow through when
they're older and they'll always
remember that change
greg
i think leadership is
two things one you've got a right
strategy for whatever organization
you're running you've got
if you've got the wrong strategy you're
stuffed anyway
but secondly you've got to get the
people who work for you the people who
are your clients
on side
and and that's difficult that takes a
lot of time and sometimes the two are so
separate the strategy you've got a
strategy to get somewhere but you can't
get the people to do it and you can't
get into it because you haven't put
yourself on the line really you haven't
gone out there and tried to say look
come on
this is what i'm trying to do this is
why we're trying to do it come with us
but but you could that's done so we have
a brief discussion only about whether
our leaders is it best to be loved or is
it best to be feared
it's best to be loved i have no doubt
about that at all it's best to be loved
and respected because then i give you
they'll give you the opportunity
that even if you get it wrong fine well
that's all we have time for this evening
it just remains for me to say thanks to
our panelists here in the studio greg
dyke
[ __ ] on windy john burko and palm sandy
of course if you at home who are at the
center of this conversation
and if you'd like to be part of the
program next time get in touch email us
at the great debate at sky dot uk
for now i want to thank everybody
on our wall and our viewers panel for
your contributions and your active
interventions we can see you there
and also
your home keep talking and we'll see you
again at the same time next week for the
great debate
[Music]
you